we're going to begin this hour though
with a look at a potential new booster
shot to fight this highly contagious
omicron variant of the coronavirus now
the fda's independent
panel rather of vaccine experts voted on
tuesday to recommend modifying the
vaccine for the first time to
specifically target omicron the goal is
to make the new boosters available this
fall ahead of the expected winter surge
now this comes amid growing concerns
about another virus that one's called
the monkey pox dr celine gallander is
here again to discuss all of this she's
an infectious disease specialist and
editor-at-large for kff's kaiser health
news always good to have you here dr
gowner so let's get right into it we'll
get to monkey pots in just a second i
know people who have gotten two boosters
two vaccines and now you're saying
another one in the fall what if they say
no i'm all boosted out what do you say
to that yeah look i think we need to
remember that the virus continues to
mutate we need to try to keep up with
the virus and even if you have gotten
two boosters so four doses i would still
strongly recommend getting the updated
booster to better match the virus that
is currently circulating but you have
people that haven't even gotten their
second booster do do you think they
should get the second booster or should
they wait or can they just skip over
that that's a good question and get the
get the the big booster that's coming
out because that's what i started to do
i heard it was coming i go i'll just
wait for that and my doctor said nope
you should go ahead and get it now and i
still got covered right well
i would if you're scheduled to get your
fourth dose go ahead and keep that
appointment um these updated vaccines
won't be out until october at the
earliest and we don't know what the
supply is going to be in october so it's
going to be a little while still yet
before you can get that updated booster
and they're different because what so
the omicron variant emerged last fall
and it has continued to mutate so you
have one two three now we're on four and
five that are starting to become the
dominant strains in the u.s and so these
updated vaccines that will come out in
the fall are to match omicron four and
five now um are we expecting a winter
surge and if so will these modified
boosters help well that's the idea as we
are expecting a winter surge people are
going to be back indoors kids back in
the classroom people are very much going
to be back at work in person definitely
by then
and these omicron sub-variants each of
them has caused an increase every time
they've emerged and so we do anticipate
that with the way number four and five
are spreading we will see a surge in the
fall except that we saw the omicron
variant appear it feels like it's very
2021 even though it's still here right
and so you're saying we're going to have
a overcrown variant targeted vaccine in
the fall but what happens when that next
variant shows up in december are you
should the cdc come out and say look
you're going to have to get shots
practically every year or come up with a
universal vaccine yeah you don't have to
keep getting these shots so what i
predict is in the short term
yearly shots will be recommended for
elderly people for people who are
immunocompromised but when there's a big
variant switch that's when everybody
will be told to get a booster but you're
right you know i think the holy grail
would be a universal corona virus
vaccine that would cover all variants
the problem is we're still years away
from that we don't have an operation
warp speed you know with lots of funding
and resources to to move that along so
it's like the flu though because we get
flu shots every year and every year the
flu is a little different it's not the
same flu shot that we received in the
prior year is that what we're looking at
well we don't know what the tempo is
going to be with the variants so will
that be a yearly switch we don't know
yet it's monkey pox let's talk about
that before you go monkey pox how
serious is it how concerned should we be
so right now monkey pox is spreading
actively among men who have sex with men
so gay men bisexual men as well as trans
women but at least in europe where they
actually are reporting the breakdown by
sex at least 10 women have gotten monkey
pox and it's only a matter of time
before this spreads on the rest of the
population monkey pox can be really
deadly and dangerous in pregnancy to the
fetus to the mom of course and to the
newborn and you know that's what we
really are trying to why we're trying to
nip this in the bud before that kind of
thing happen so how do you protect
yourself against monkey pox well it's
spread by direct contact with people who
are infected with their active lesions
which could be anywhere on the skin as
well as the mouth
the genitalia the anus so those are all
areas that could be infectious you can
reduce your risk of spread by say using
condoms but that's only going to reduce
risk of spread
with the skin that's covered and if you
get it is there a vaccine is there a
pill is there a vaccine there is a
vaccine so that's being released from
the strategic national stockpile now and
we're trying to accelerate the finishing
completion of doses that are with the
manufacturer right now
all right dr celine gander always great
to have you important information thank
you very much